nuevas medidas en francia para frenar el
avance de una nueva ola de kobe 19 será
obligatoria la dosis de refuerzo para
todos los adultos hasta hoy sólo era un
requisito para los mayores de 65 años
trabajadores de la salud o personas con
condiciones especiales de salud luego
tenemos el destino en nuestras manos el
pase de vacunación o prueba negativa de
kobe 19 seguirá siendo obligatorio para
ingresar a restaurantes bares gimnasios
y otros lugares públicos a partir del 15
de enero todas las personas deberán
mostrar que tienen la dosis de refuerzo
algunos franceses les molesta la medida
no la idea de las dos primeras dosis sin
ningún problema así que para la tercera
dosis porque no lo único que me irrita
es que sea obligatorio el uso de
mascarillas en espacios cerrados también
será obligatorio de nuevo a partir de
este viernes sin embargo las autoridades
descartaron re imponer un confinamiento
mientras en los territorios insulares
franceses las protestas por la
vacunación obligatoria continúan en la
isla de martinica hubo bloqueos en las
calles además durante la noche fueron
incendiados carros y saqueados locales
comerciales por lo que se decretó el
toque de queda en guadalupe la situación
es similar los manifestantes han
bloqueado vías y la atención no cede